[Musique]
rageur mais grh denis récit draguer
d'osiris quelques minutes
chers citoyens de russie chers amis non
seulement quelques minutes prendra fin
l'année 2020 célébrant son début il y à
exactement un an
comme tous de par le monde nous pensions
rêvions de changement qui irait dans la
bonne direction
personne ne pouvait alors imaginer
quelle épreuve nous allions tous
traversés et il semble aujourd'hui que
l'année qui s'achève a pris sur elle le
fardeau de plusieurs années grosse ni à
ce calcul est trop de noms elle aura été
difficile pour chacun d'entre nous
pleine d'angoissés de considérables
contraintes matérielles d'inquiétude et
pour certains de la perte douloureuse de
proches et de ceux qu'ils aimaient
néanmoins l'année qui s'achève aura été
de toute évidence marqué par l'espoir de
surmonter les épreuves par la fierté
envers ceux qui ont fait preuve des
meilleures qualités humaines et
professionnelles par la prise de
conscience de l'importance capitale de
vraie relation durable et sincère entre
les gens l'amitié et la confiance entre
nous tous d'avis à l'image de neymar à
chenôve mist nous avons vécu cette année
ensemble dignement comme il s'y est un
peuple uni qui honore les traditions de
ses ancêtres
ces valeurs telles que le courage la
réceptivité et la clémence sont
enracinées dans nos coeurs notre
caractère et noack ça on a donc réactivé
et passe tout non pour modèle nos chers
anciens combattants la vaillante
génération des vainqueurs du fléau du
nazisme
en dépit de tout nous avons rempli notre
devoir filial sacré en célébrant avec
gratitude et reconnaissance
le 75e anniversaire de la grande
victoire il occupa gamme mini opéra oui
le nouveau et dangereux virus a perturbé
bouleverser notre mode de vie de travail
et d'étude habituel il nous a forcés à
réviser
ajustez beaucoup de projets mais c'est
ainsi que bâle au monde
les épreuves sont inévitables elle nous
pousse à considérer la vie plus
attentivement à écouter sa conscience à
mettre de côté ce qui est insignifiant
et 20 et à vraiment apprécier ce qui est
le plus important
le don de la vie humaine la famille nos
mères et nos pères nos grands pères et
nos grands mères nos enfants les nouveau
nés comme ceux qui ont déjà grandi nos
amis et nos collègues l'aide
désintéressée et l'énergie comme une des
bonnes actions grande à l'échelle du
pays
comme petit au niveau d'un quartier
d'une rue d'un immeuble mais tout aussi
importante
on être ni menace nature espagne évident
les épreuves et le fléau past
inévitablement à cela a toujours été le
cas
reste le plus important tout ce qui nous
rend généreux efforts
l'amour la compréhension mutuelle la
confiance le soutien par conséquent je
tiens à vous souhaiter que les
difficultés de l'année qui s'achève
fasse le plus vite possible partie du
passé et que tout ce que nous avons
acquis les meilleures qualités qui se
sont fait jour en chacun d'entre nous
restent avec nous a jamais caché 9,6 de
ses moyens aujourd'hui il est très
important de croire en soi de ne pas
reculer face aux difficultés de chérir
notre solidarité
ce sont là les fondements de nos succès
commun à venir je suis convaincu
qu'ensemble nous surmonterons tous nous
remettrons les choses en ordre et nous
reviendrons à une vie normale et avec
une vigueur renouvelée
nous continuerons de résoudre les défis
auxquels la russie est confrontée dans
cette troisième décennie du 21ème siècle
qui est sur le point de commencer
chers amis nous ne sommes pas à l'heure
actuelle tous réunis autour d'une table
de fête
beaucoup de gens se trouvent dans les
hôpitaux et je suis convaincu qu'ils
ressentent tout le soutien de leurs
proches et de leurs amis de tout coeur
je vous souhaite chers amis de vaincre
la maladie et de rentrer chez vous le
plus vite possible moi jeune homme
austère
nous n'avons malheureusement pas encore
réussi à mettre complètement fin à
l'épidémie
la lutte contre elle ne s'arrête à aucun
moment les médecins et infirmiers les
équipes médicales d'urgence continuent à
travailler avec courage beaucoup d'entre
eux sont de service en cette nuit de
fête
de même sans relâche et avec une grande
responsabilité
les services d'urgence les militaires
dans les zones où la situation est
tendue à l'étranger les forces de
maintien de la paix et les équipes de
combat de l'armée et de la flotte
accomplissent des missions extrêmement
difficile grâce à tous ceux qui
accomplissent leur devoir jour et nuit
qui sont à leur poste en toutes
circonstances les citoyens russes
peuvent se réunir tranquillement
aujourd'hui au sein de leur foyer avec
leur famille célébrer le nouvel an en
espérant que tout aille pour le mieux
avec des projets pour l'avenir faire des
voeux secret chers amis
rêvons dans ces moments-là aux choses
les plus heureuses la paix et le
bien-être le bonheur et la joie pour
tous ceux qui sont près de nous qui nous
sont chères pour l'ensemble de notre
pays d'origine à chastre année je tiens
à remercier chacun d'entre vous parce
que nous sommes ensemble cantons sont
l'esprit de groupe des gens qui se
tiennent près de nous la russie devient
une seule grande famille je vous
souhaite sincèrement à tous comme à ceux
qui me sont proches et cher une bonne
santé fois espoir et amour risque draghi